hey everyone my name is jake host and
producer of the gamespot after dark
podcast
this week we had alex jordan on who lent
his voice to the incredible demon souls
remake
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to hear the full interview just search
for gamespot after dark on your podcast
provider of choice
also be sure to check out alex's twitch
channel where he regularly raises money
for charity
anyway with all that out of the way
let's roll the clip
just very quickly i can't believe we're
like 15 minutes in
and we haven't discussed demon souls i
was about to
dance at your restraint
trying to be restrained but obviously
demon souls
one of my favorite games of all time i
i've seen your love on
it twitter a public love it's a public
love it's a very public love yeah
it is i have no shame about my love for
souls games
and i mean you're in you you played the
hero character
in yeah and then the remake right which
male
male voice selections in the character
selection yeah yeah
one of my favorite one of my favorite
things to do is or if you haven't seen
it is to go to
alex's uh twitter and there's a video i
think it's still there it might be your
young tweet of you doing the voice i
remember seeing that a while back and
you're like in a booth
just uh swinging around what is i think
a wrench
yep and making like noises
oh yeah so this is the thing so all the
swords but the problem is with all the
wires around
i wouldn't be able to be swinging that
in fact
and some of them are sharp some of them
are really sharp um
yeah demon souls was um a huge amount of
fun
and was actually quite
quite a bit more recording than you
might think
um the variables the the multiple
different um like sort of degrees of
grunting
for many different possible sort of you
know
um hits that you receive or that you
deal
out and stuff you know so we've got sort
of a medium sword
um sort of slash so going up from like
low to medium intensity to high
intensity then you have so you have like
12 of them
i mean it's it's a lot and we recorded
um
we recorded a good amount of it on uh
i'm so sorry lucy's camera just died for
those listening cameras just died and
it's an
amazing rubber pads and batman
[Music]
[Laughter]
i tried really hard to carry on through
my sentence
and i couldn't oh god i'm sorry yeah
which is um
my camera died and it said the battery's
low which is worrying because it's
plugged in
you just have to turn it off and on
again mike does that all the time
uh how do i get back on to where where
was i
swinging uh swinging a wrench in a
wrench
um so we recorded a lot of the demon
soul stuff
um the height of summer heatwave
in uh london and
like i i went in knowing it was gonna be
hot because um
you're recording in a small booth with a
lot of sort of fabric and
um sound proofing um and it's got to be
sealed off from the outside it's boiling
and you sweat
a lot um so the one that i've got on my
twitter is before that but the second
one when it was really hot i literally
went in
in just like this very thin t-shirt and
a pair of swimming shots
and i went in and recorded in that and
came out
just like i'm so glad i made the
decision to wear swimming shorts today
because it was it was i was dripping
um because you do get really into the in
order to make it believable you get
really into the the sort of the the
bodily movements
of it well that sounds kind of like
um but yeah how much did you know about
demon souls before getting
the gig for it were you like intimately
familiar or how much of the
where you nervous about it to any degree
because i imagine
someone who knows that franchise will
know oh god this is like one of the
biggest games ever
yeah it's it was i'd never played
on well i played but i never owned a
souls game
i played souls games many times round of
friends you know
that i'd also vicariously lived it
through streams and stuff like that
so i was i was super aware of
the importance of the game and um
sort of what it what it could be if done
right
um was i nervous
kind of to a degree i guess because all
my stuff was um
was more uh grunt based and
character movement based there was a
little less
not riding on it but i felt a little
less of that pressure i would say
um i think if i was going back
and re-dubbing characters that people
knew and loved before
then i would be absolutely uh bricking
it 100
um i'd understand the pressure but i
guess because as well the
that that character playable hero
vocal element was in itself like a new
thing
yeah so there wasn't any uh any bar
already set or anything or any previous
experience that players had that i had
to live up to
i had to worry about and i got to be
able to go okay well cool i'm used to
doing this like with other games
just got to kind of treat it like any
other game but no i definitely
definitely knew um what it was i was
working on and how lucky i was to be
working on it and
it was so painful to be silenced in
like bound by nda silence for months
having seen
having seen gameplay having seen how it
was looking and what it was going to be
like
i i mean it was just
so hard to to not want to talk about it
and tell everyone to go
guys they've made they've even made
puddles
look beautiful like puddles like you
could stop and spend time looking at the
puddles and appreciate
puddles that's how beautiful they've
like a job they've done and it
i think they absolutely nailed it they
were fantastic they're fantastic job on
it
i uh i played a lot of demon souls as
well as as well as tomorrow but i played
with headphones for almost the entire
time so i had that
kind of what is it 3d audio experience
but uh
tempest 3d audio from sony
thank you so good when it's coming from
batman
um how how much like
i i've heard your you breathe a lot
because of that was there any
like really weird sounds or grunts or
like
setups to different grunts that you had
that you're like how am i supposed to
make this sound different from like
getting hit with a sword or
something along those lines 100 100
there's one
that i really love so i really like
dropping in
to streams and catching it and seeing
people play it i love
doing it and i um i guess you could say
there's a degree of
vanity to that but there's also i think
games are themselves interactive
um and so like so twitch has added to
that interactivity and i love just
stopping by and saying hey thanks for
playing the game i appreciate because i
feel like it's just an
extension of that interactivity and
there's one bit which whenever i drop in
a stream if i manage to catch it there's
one sound and
i love to hear it back because i'm like
that moment in that booth was like what
the hell
am i doing right now what's this and
it's the moment that
um the uh mind flayer sort of like so
you get impaled
and you're being electrocuted um and
there's kind of like
you so you've just been impaled there's
like a degree of electrocution there's a
degree of kind of like
electricity running through your body
and kind of this shock but you're
gargling and you're dying and that kind
of
that
that moment that kind of like sort of
noise
you have to bring it down and not make
it sound too comical
yeah um that one was definitely one and
also just the breathing just like okay
now give us like
give us a sustained period of like
medium
jog breathing and you're there just
going
and then like and then because as well
because you
you're just going for it you're just
kind of looking like glancing through
the booth through
through the glass like do i just keep
keep going when
is someone gonna stop me am i just no
i'm gonna okay i'm gonna keep going
there's always like souls games that
always have that one
very awkward noise that their character
makes when they die which sounds like a
an intimate release let's call it and
i've always been fascinated with the
like the voice actors that do that
because there's that one when you die
and
they just go ugh that's weird what is
that all about did you have to do the
uh intimate release voice at any point
this is the thing intermittently the
title of this episode
i think there's there's a there's
actually so many of those and i think
there's so many of those that maybe in
the moment
in the moment of playing the game kind
of uh
the player may miss because they're kind
of a lot softer
um and yeah i mean with any kind of game
that has any kind of action death scene
sequence
uh there's always they go okay now give
us like a breathy one and it is very
much like
and you definitely do kind of like you
you all have that moment where you go
everyone looks at each other everyone
goes okay we know what that sounded like
we know what that could be used for
but we all know the context of this so
we all go was that a good take
yes it was in the context
the only time people hear that is when
you're being stepped on by a dragon
exactly not in the way most people would
want it on the internet
some people might want to be stepped on
by dragon ball i mean i would probably
pay to see that yeah yeah did you
did you um in terms of who you kind of
uh
interfaced with um mostly while doing
your
um performances was it specifically like
a production company or was it sony or
from software did you meet any of those
those guys or have any involvement with
them
so uh sometimes there's certain games
you get where you you come to know the
directors a lot more
other games it's kind of quite fleeting
so i think we did
two sessions on demon souls um
and to be honest it was so long ago that
sort of like when you go in and you do
it
you do meet people and then you kind of
touch base with them again the next time
but you
it's difficult to know exactly in the
moment what their exact role is
in the in in the the development of the
of the game uh whereas demon souls was
very much and i mean as well when you've
got multiple people and then sometimes
you've got someone in the room but
you've also got a couple of people
on uh link you know sort of like linking
up via
uh skype or something like that it's
very difficult to kind of pin down
um so in that moment yeah i wasn't in i
wasn't entirely sure who
i was interacting with at what point um
and as well when there's a when there's
a degree of
of kind of i guess secrecy maybe isn't
the word but uh
some kind of um kind of you know people
just wanted to keep things close
uh you don't wanna you're not sure how
much you can ask
you know yeah i guess i was just i guess
i was just asking because like
do you foresee yourself you know the the
souls games they
whether it's from whether it's sony or
whether it's publisher bandai they love
to bring back voice actors
to you know um be in other games like
you know the the voice actor for the
maiden and black and demon souls is also
lady murray and bloodborne and
etc etc you've got commonalities do you
do you want to be involved
i mean you're an actor who wants to work
so i assume the answer is yes but like
do you do you foresee yourself trying to
get into another demon souls game are
you already in
elder ring do and you're just keeping it
a secret from us like tell us
um so yeah 100 i would love to work with
with the prompt software bluepoint you
know
i'd love to work with i think they they
they do fantastic work
um and yeah i'd absolutely love to um
i'm not in eldon ring
so i just said i'm not an elderly
but uh but yeah no it is it is really
great when you get to work with
people that you work with before um
and you you kind of you get to
understand the way they work
they get to understand the way you work
and i feel like you just get stronger
and stronger in your kind of
performances and everything
um it is it is an interesting one
because the
because the time in which a game like
the amount of time it takes for a game
to
go through all of its stages until you
know it's release
it is such a long development there's
there's so much that goes into it
um but i guess there's there's times
where i'm thinking
i'm hoping further down the line i'll
work with these people again but i'm
going
i mean we're still just working on this
one and then
i mean the next thing that comes out
could be way down the line you know
we've got the release then we've got
right
obviously there'll be more some some
students have multiple projects at once
but it is compared to things like doing
a play or
uh doing a film i feel like there's just
just a much longer amount of time that
goes into
into it into the development of it um so
who knows maybe further down the line
but i i feel like
i guess what am i now i've been doing
this for six seven years so maybe we'll
start to get into that territory now
where i'm like right i'm really starting
to clock around and come back and work
with companies
uh multiple times um yeah fingers
crossed
fingers crossed
[Music]
you